hello I'm Paul you can [ __ ] lead
product manager for Azure deaf
experience this year there's just been
an incredible uptake of containers in
the industry in services and in
distributed applications and it totally
makes sense
because it helps us get density it helps
us make more portable applications with
dependencies and it really speeds up
that end-to-end DevOps pipeline Visual
Studio 2019 also upped its game adding
all kinds of tools to make you
productive adding containers to things
as simple as individual services all the
way up to complicated distributed
applications using kubernetes let's go
check it out so we're inside Visual
Studio 2019 what I want to do is create
a myriad of different services ranging
from really simple all the way to a more
sophisticated distributed application
let's create a new project will choose
asp.net core and I want to create a web
front-end I like MVC will turn on HTTP
and let's get going
so at this point this is business as
usual we have a web application loaded
in Visual Studio I can run it inside a
vias Express and have that really fast
inner loop in Visual Studio when I want
to containerize what I would do is add
docker support we'll take the defaults
and really all that does is we add a
docker file to the project so that tells
us how to build a docker container one
thing to know visual studio by default
in debug mode it'll really use this
first from statement the rest of this is
used by the release configuration and
typically in a CI CD pipeline that's
where these different stages are
important because well build will build
a release package and then we'll
finalize but we'll actually get rid of
all those interstitial files so that'll
give you a cleaner better ready for
release container and we also set the
run target for the debugger to docker so
I can let's say open a controller set a
breakpoint now that we've set the
breakpoint
we can f5 and run inside of docker we'll
make sure we have all the base images
will create a docker image for you we'll
start that image and we'll run and we
can see at this point it is still just
business as usual we're running our web
application inside of the docker desktop
environment getting the production
realism but also when we hit our
controller we're getting full visual
studio debugging with everything you
know and love about debugging and at
this point what I can do is I could
let's say publish to the azure container
registry or more often what we're seeing
developer teams do is we'll set up CI CD
pipelines using let's say Azure DevOps
and we will continuously deploy the
source code including docker up to Azure
now let's take this a little bit further
I mentioned that we can integrate with a
DevOps lifecycle one really crucial part
of that is unit testing so let's also
just add a unit test the way we always
do in net so what I'll do is I'll add a
new project you can see there's all
different kinds of tests whether it's X
unit or any unit in this case I'll
choose X unit and I like to follow the
convention of taking my project name and
adding test tests at the end will create
that ok and I have a very simple test
harness with a stubbed-out method to
test what I also want to do is add a
reference for my test project back to
the original web project that I'm
testing and just for the sake of time
we'll add a fictitious test so let's
assert false and we'll pass in a false
value of course you would stream a real
input from a method in the web app and
will negate ourselves with a little
message here so this is the world's
simplest unit test that we're going to
run and I can go ahead and in the test
Explorer I can see that this test was
created and I can run all
cool and I can see visual studio.net
just seamlessly worked with a simple web
application project that was also
containerized but in this case I'm
actually still not running the unit test
inside of a container so let's go ahead
and see what that would look like so I'm
going to just use the same steps I will
add docker support we'll choose the
defaults in this case I get a default
docker file now what I want to do is I
want to run inside of a container that
actually has our SDK CLI and build tools
so this runtime image that I have that's
a little bit too slim so let's pick one
that actually has the SDK it will match
the version number so SDK 2.1 i like the
working der now what i want to do is
make sure that all the files are copied
into the container from my test
directory and last i want to run a unit
test and that's just what we already
know from the CLI we say dotnet test and
that's it this again is very simple this
is something that we'll unit tests at f5
what I'd probably really want to do in
the fullness of time is I want to hook
and create a test target after the build
and publish happens so when I hook up to
CI CD that's what I'll eventually do but
let's try this now let's run this test
project as the startup so we can really
see it and you can see that the docker
build process is actually happening the
background in our dotnet test layer is
being run as well
and the most important thing is we can
see that our test results it flew by our
test results past so let's pop back over
just to take a quick peek so we can see
that after this layer ran we got that
CLI output actually integrated as a part
of our build process so this can work
inside a visual studio this can work at
the command line this could work in
PowerShell and this can also work in
your DevOps pipeline just seamlessly
integrate testing into your container
workflow and it's as simple as that okay
so now we have a simple service with a
simple test and I want to show you how
we can even scale out a bit more from
here so typically when I think about
containers it's not only isolation of
Penn C's but it's also really tiny and
that allows me to do things like
microservices in the end I'll have maybe
many micro services or many services so
let's look at what that would be I'm
gonna set this main project back to my
startup and what I'll do is I'll add
another project will pick web again but
this time I want a Web API and think of
this you know this is my front end API
and maybe add I'd have some workers as
well I'll just call that py API and
we'll choose the API option we'll keep
the other defaults all right now I've
scaffolded out that web api project and
you guessed it if I want to dock your
eyes this project I add docker support I
get the defaults here and in this case I
could just run my solution with multiple
startup projects
you
like so and notice how the solution is
the startup and this would give me two
isolated containers running side by side
but at that point there's no
orchestration and so what we see now is
that there are a set of apps where it
actually makes sense to have
orchestration with things like service
discovery things like routing things
like load balancing so in that case we
have some more options for you there as
well I'm gonna set this back to my
startup project I sure this one back to
my startup project and let's add
orchestration so we'll pick container
orchestration support and Visual Studio
has support for several orchestrators
I'm going to pick kubernetes and help
but there's also service fabric and
docker compose so you have plenty of
ecosystem options to do the
orchestration let's add kubernetes and
at this point what the tooling is doing
is it's scaffolding out the helm charts
in the kubernetes manifests that are
needed to run these containers inside of
not only docker but inside of kubernetes
with orchestration and I would repeat
that for every service that I want to be
a part of kubernetes so let's add
container orchestration here we'll pick
helm at this point I've really taken
dotnet applications
I made them ready for containers and
I've made them ready for kubernetes and
a cool thing to point out here is we
have a new service called
azure dev spaces Azure dev spaces makes
it easy to build and run inside of
kubernetes inside of azure so you're
effectively doing a remote f5 but even
more importantly it allows me as an
individual developer to work in a team
on my services without impacting
everyone else in the team so that would
be the up command into azure dev spaces
which we do every time you f5 so as you
can see it was really easy to start with
a simple service and then just scale out
from there ad
services add tests and at any point I'm
actually not locked in to still run is
kubernetes or to run in the docker
environment I can actually still quite
simply switch back to is Express or
switch back to docker and that allows me
to maybe run really fast or to do things
on my machine because I already have my
machine set up so I just want to point
out you really have that flexibility to
move throughout this continuum and work
the way that your team wants to work so
as we just saw we were able to use
Visual Studio 2019 to really leverage
all the things going on in the ecosystem
around containers we have images for
dotnet Cornette framework we saw linux
windows all different kinds of distros
of linux and we really saw that
continuum between again simple services
using just docker files all the way up
to distributed applications using
kubernetes and home also of course you
would expect the best-in-class debugger
from Visual Studio we saw that works
seamlessly inside of containers another
notable thing is you can easily even
debug kubernetes up in the cloud using
Azure dev spaces and it has that
additional benefit of you get isolation
while testing and debugging in the cloud
with your own services amongst the fleet
of other services last we really worked
on that flexibility so that you can
debug and run straight to the metal
using is Express or inside of a docker
container or inside of kubernetes so
depending on whether you want to be
really fast or really have that
production realism you have a whole
spectrum of options we also make sure
that you have the flexibility to hook
into your DevOps pipeline doing things
like running unit tests having
multistage builds so you can control the
phases and hooking well into Azure
DevOps so with all that said what I
would ask you to all do
go get Visual Studio 2019 make sure you
have the web and Azure workloads
installed that'll give you all of the
container tools try it out check it out
let us know what you think thank you
you
[Music]